[Music]
uh all right let's uh let's move on to a
question from twitter amaya has a
question for us what are your thoughts
on this twitter thread about the danger
of minimalist design and the death of
detail okay so i had malabama print this
out for me so i can just pass these on
the first thing i'm looking at here this
is a whole twitter thread we'll put a
link to this in the show notes by the
way and really what they're illustrating
here is when you take
simplicity or simplifying that
simplicity you take simplifying too far
when you see something that is ornate it
may be too ornate and then the pendulum
swings the other way we see this all the
time where someone goes from being a
hoarder to a spartanist over the course
of a year and then they can't hold on to
anything it's like being stuck and
frozen onto the monkey bars but then
someone put butter all of your hands and
now you can't hold on to anything at all
so to me this is when minimalism design
goes bad in some respects however i'll
say that some of these just look much
better to me i mean they look more
aesthetically pleasing the question is
do you lose function
because you've made form a god of sorts
so here's the first one it's just like a
little parking cone or parking pole that
prevents people from running up on a
curb and to me that just looks
appreciably better we'll put these up on
the screen as well jordan if you want to
put them right here above my hand
somewhere we'll put these on the screen
so you can see them if you are watching
the video version of the podcast the
next one here is some railing for a
fence and
what i'll say is again this to me looks
appreciably better
even though it has a lack of detail as
pointed out in the tweet although i
would say if it makes it less safe that
would be a problem
although are you saying you like the
minimalist one more and not certainly
absolutely and you do not
yeah you're mad
[Laughter]
and so here's what i'll say and we we
did this recently we did ryan and i did
a minimalist architecture private
podcast it was a long podcast we
reviewed a bunch of minimalist
architecture and what i said in that
episode was this
if
everyone i'm a fan of brutalism who am i
actually i'm a fan of brutalism but if
we were to prescribe that on to everyone
everyone now must live under brutalism
if you talk about the soviet union yeah
you're talking about forcing that on to
people and so what i'll say to amaya is
minimalism is a tool it's not a
prescription and so these things they
actually look better to me
if the minimalist guard rail was less
safe than the really ornate slightly
uglier guard rail then i would say oh
you don't want form
to
trump function however here's the weird
thing about guard rails there's data
around this if you go to
the grand canyon
the places where people die most
frequently are the places with
guardrails
because we overstep our bounds when
these artificial boundaries are set up
and so we try to climb on top of them or
stand on top of the guard rails and so
people die most frequently at the guard
rails if there isn't a guardrail there
they stand a few feet back and then they
don't stand in danger so maybe here the
most minimalist design would be to
remove the guard rail altogether i'm
just imagining if you were president it
would be reading shupenhar and brutalist
architecture that's terrifying
and i love it i would be i'd be happy
but i don't know if many other people
would
i think i would amplify it but i would
not prescribe it yes yeah and i think
that maybe the power would get to your
head yes yes i will become the tyrant
and here's the one we might disagree
with the most here so we'll put this on
the screen it'll be in color on the
screen but i'm handing over black and
white this is a old british red phone
booth versus like an american minimalist
phone booth
and while i can appreciate the
old british charm
of the red phone booth
let's face it we don't even have phone
booths at all anymore so all of this has
been rendered irrelevant anyway
what are your thoughts on this this is
where the minimalists get controversial
this is where you're going to get
cancelled for not liking the red
foonboth
i mean that's a design classic that red
phone but but you're right that they're
kind of like uh
redundant now yeah and so i think quite
often over time the things that were
beautiful
they
still become
they're still beautiful but they become
useless sometimes right and it's not
that art needs to be useful in fact most
great art has no utilitarian use
whatsoever that's not why we enjoy art
i've never been to like the lack of i
walked in and saw it's a beautiful
painting but what are we going to use it
for yep it's it transcends that in a way
it's interesting because it's
the thread is titled the danger of
minimalist design
and that and then the death of detail so
i'm not sure if the phone booth you know
falls in that category i don't see
anything dangerous about this but
whatever maybe it should be titled the
danger of dangerous design or the danger
of things i don't like who knows
here's something that's interesting to
me there's a line here where he says
it is a troubling phenomenon because of
what minimalism represents
what does minimalism represent
apparently i was wrong on what i thought
it was because it represents a lack of
detail
and that's an interesting that's an
interesting claim
i don't know any minimalists who
actually say that minimalism represents
a lack of detail it represents a lack of
excess yes and there's a huge difference
right because
it's sort of like writing say everything
that you need to say for the story that
you're telling and not a word more now
if the story that i'm telling isn't
designed to entertain but it's merely
designed to convey directions about how
to get to the grocery store then i'm
gonna have only a certain amount of
detail if the purpose of the story is to
make you laugh or to entertain i might
need 20 words just to describe a blade
of grass there's no objective amount of
detail that's too much it's based on
what's the story you're trying to sell
what's the purpose you're trying to
achieve and to go beyond that is excess
how do you know you have excess
when what you have is making you feel
overwhelmed making you feel stressed out
making you feel in over your head you
can discern by your own internal compass
whether your relationship with something
constitutes excess or not it's not about
how big or small something is professor
sean you had a note that you wanted to
add
yeah um talking about danger here um one
of the examples was the
parking bollard i had a friend who
tore his scrotum jumping over an overly
designed parking ballard and that would
not have happened with the minimalist
one
so it would not have happened if your
friend wasn't an idiot
this is true i think it was a parkour
accident you can't blame the pole on
that one well i will say this if you
embrace minimalism you're protecting
your balls yes
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free